[Music]
on this Tuesday night Nova Scotia RCMP
under intensifying scrutiny why didn't
they request an emergency alert when a
mass murderer was on the loose that is
something that all Nova Scotians are
wondering new details about the innocent
lives lost she was a beautiful human
being the growing death toll and the
renewed focus on gun control doctors and
nurses orders Quebec's new investigation
into how Kovac 19 is devastating care
homes and stitching together a Canadian
solution I'm really proud to be a part
of this a common thread between these
face mask makers
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin in Nova Scotia in questions
about whether lives could have been
saved in that shooting rampage had an
emergency alert been issued warning
people an armed and dangerous man was in
the area
the RCMP now say they believe 22 people
were killed plus the gunman leaving the
possibility open there could be even
more victims found among those being
more under health care workers a teacher
an RCMP officer a 17 year old all of
them victims of the worst mass killing
in Canadian history
the RCMP didn't hold a briefing today
they did issue a release it says the
first call came in at 10:30 on Saturday
night a firearms complaint in the town
of Porter pickle on Twitter
the RCMP advised the public to stay
inside and lock their doors when police
arrived the gunman was gone and they
were casualties inside and outside the
home the gunman kept roaming through the
night but an emergency alert was never
issued Nova Scotia's Premier Stephen
McNeil says the emergency management
office was ready to issue one but did
not get a request from the RCMP our amo
Center was activated has been activated
we brought in staff that had come in
those that especially deal with the
alert system and yes we need to be the
lead agency in this case the RCMP has to
ask for that alert to quote but we added
staff on hand in the morning to be able
to do that and but it was not requested
the RCMP say the gunman was wearing an
authentic police uniform and driving
what they call a very real look-alike
RCMP vehicle they say he did not have a
criminal record our CMP say 13 and a
half hours past from when the first call
came in to when the gunman was shot by
police and later died at a service
station in Enfield the RCMP aren't
speculating on his motives and we have
been asked why we've shown his picture
and used his name well we're being
careful to limit how often we do that
but we're not going to withhold any
information because he is responsible
for multiple murders and with 16 crime
scenes there are many unanswered
questions including about the police
response
Ross Lord has covered this
since it broken begins our coverage
tonight this country road is popular for
walking now in the small community of
Wentworth Nova Scotia it's a symbol of
randomness David and Heather Matthews
decided Sunday morning to alter their
normal path I come out of the driveway
and I said no I'm not walking down the
road and I don't know why that decision
might have saved their lives
minutes later they heard the sound of
what they now believe was a gunshot that
took the life of Lil Ian Hislop who was
also a regular Walker Lilian was a
gentle person
sweet lady very community spirit
she walked almost every day Heather
Matthews feels if RCMP had initiated a
widespread warning instead of using
primarily Twitter the outcome could have
been different I was wondering why we
could not have received an alert of some
kind we get kovat 9:19 alerts we get
Amber Alerts some kind of an alert to
warn us that there was someone loose and
that perhaps if that occurred on our
devices televisions radios telephones
perhaps Lilian would still be living
along with hard questions there are
endless acts of tribute to the gunman's
unsuspecting victims it's absolutely
devastating
Erin Barclay knew five victims including
teacher Lisa McCauley known as a
dedicated mother of two children nobody
in their right mind would want to kill
her or anybody there's probably not a
child in this school or any of the local
schools that don't have a relative or a
close friend that that passed away over
this weekend people in these hardest hit
communities also crave a day that
doesn't reveal even worse information
about what happened Ross Laura Global
News de Burt Nova Scotia a Canadian
military has said it will be supporting
the investigation in Nova Scotia
providing tents generators and lights to
help protect and process the crime
scenes about 30 forces members will be
involved this crime leaves a huge hole
in the community and in the hearts of
those who are grieving tonight
sometimes it's
editorial cartoonists who capture the
moment best this one is by brian gable
in The Globe and Mail communities in
Nova Scotia are facing not just the
terrible loss but the fact they can't
gather together to grieve because of the
pandemic funerals are limited to five
people immediate family only might relay
has more on those who were killed and
those who are mourning retirement in
Nova Scotia was always the dream for
Franklin Chen and Don Madsen they bought
a home and lived apart as Frank fixed it
up and only recently reunited to enjoy a
calmer East Coast lifestyle just to
finally you know reach her dream to have
it taken away six months later this is
just it's horrifying it's essentially
not what she worked her her life for Don
had worked for 18 years in food service
at a Toronto Area retirement home she
will always hold a special part in my
heart where she was remembered for
treating and advocating for all the
residents as if they were family tell
you straight up whether it's gonna be
negative or positive
it didn't matter she was honest totally
honest there are times that I didn't
want her to be that honest but
nonetheless I do appreciate the fact
that she was honest and gave me the
feedback so much is still unknown as to
what happened and how any of these
people could be linked to the madness
that unfolded over the weekend makes
absolutely no sense and it's extremely
tragic Kris Williams now retired from
the RCMP trained to become an officer
with constable Heidi Stevenson in 1995
he says she never changed over the years
she was always that East Coaster with a
big heart and a bigger smile his sadness
at the loss of a friend is mixed with
the need for answers I think we all have
questions first and foremost beyond the
details I just want to say that my heart
goes out to Heidi and to her children I
cannot imagine the loss that they're
feeling today how can anybody imagine
any of it
Joey Weber lives far away from the crime
scenes but fate had him doing an errand
for his family
which he valued above all else I would I
would regularly see him on my morning
drives into City Hall taking his
children to to the bus stop and he
always had a big smile and always waved
the victims came from all walks of life
brought together in a way never thought
possible microlight Global News Toronto
the Queen has sent a message of
condolence to Nova Scotia she writes
that she and Prince Philip are deeply
saddened by the appalling events and she
offered words of support for the police
officers who she says are selflessly
responding to these devastating attacks
and to the emergency services who are
supporting those who have been injured
and affected after any incident of mass
violence the question often turns to how
those responsible acquired their weapons
my click ature is with me from Ottawa
Mike this tragedy in Nova Scotia is
bringing some legislation back to the
forefront well Donna police still
haven't said what gun or guns the
shooter used to inflict so much damage
over the course of nearly 14 hours in
Nova Scotia but that hasn't stopped the
federal government from talking about
gun control legislation the Prime
Minister has continually said the focus
right now is to support the families of
those who lost loved ones in the same
breath Justin Trudeau talks about gun
control legislation that his party was
ready to introduce before Parliament was
suspended due to the Cova 19 outbreak
now we still haven't seen the bill just
yet but it would likely be based on
their campaign promise which included a
ban and buyback program on what the
government calls assault rifles giving
cities the power to restrict or ban
handguns and red flag laws for people
who could be a danger to others the
legislation on the assault rifle ban was
ready almost ready to go when we when
Parliament suspended so I expect that'll
be the first measures we bring forward
but of course as we learn more about
this terrible terrible tragedy in Nova
Scotia
we will keep reflecting on ways that we
need to help Canadians stay safe no any
new gun law
we'll have to wait until May 25th at the
earliest
that's when Parliament is scheduled to
reconvene the special in-person and
virtual meetings of the House of Commons
over the next month are only to discuss
matters related to kovat 19 Donna all
right Mike ligature in Ottawa Thanks
now to the other story that's dominated
the news and your lives for more than
six weeks now there are more than 38,000
confirmed cases of kovat 19 in Canada
and more than 1800 deaths the number of
new cases varies widely depending on the
region an Ontario and Quebec have the
biggest numbers in Ontario more than
11,000 people are known to have kovat 19
a jump of 551 and more than 600 people
have died Quebec has more than 20,000
confirmed cases a rise of 807 and 102
more people died there bringing the
number of dead in Quebec to more than
1,000 that is the most of any province
and the majority of those who died 850
were in long term care homes or others
senior residences staffing in those
facilities has been hit hard to Quebec
said today about one in five positive
cases our health care workers Mike
Armstrong explains the huge toll that's
putting on the system going into this
crisis experts new long-term care
facilities were vulnerable but kovat 19
got to them anyway the professional
orders representing Quebec doctors
nurses and auxiliary nurses announced
Tuesday eight joint investigation into
what went wrong Amanda Lee the head of
the auxiliary nurses says they want to
know whether it was a question of
training or equipment shortages or
something else that let the virus in
what's happened has been devastating in
Quebec 300 long-term care facilities
have had at least one case the outbreaks
in 80 are still not under control one of
those facilities has now had eight first
health care worker died Vickie Sullivan
worked as an orderly at the grace dart
Center for 25 years her last shift was
April 11th she died of kovat 19 just six
days later it was a reminder to everyone
the work being done in these facilities
and be dangerous I think about it every
day clark's healthcare minister says
she's well aware of the danger and the
toll it's taking in a province with just
over 20,000 kovat 19 cases about 1 in 5
as a health care worker in some areas
around Montreal the ratios even higher
between positive tests preventive leave
burnout and anxiety about 6000 health
care workers are off the job for the
ones still working there's frustration
as supplies of protective gear are only
starting to fill the demand we're
playing catch-up and obviously our
members all of them are asking questions
about this type of thing more and more
of the government's focus is now
targeting long-term care facilities one
plan that's just started is to move
healthcare workers from other parts of
the province to hard-hit areas like
Montreal they'll be put up in hotels and
dedicated to one facility for two weeks
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal a
worker has died from Kovac 19:00 and
hundreds more are sick after an outbreak
forced a meatpacking plant to close in
southern Alberta the Cargill meatpacking
plant employs more than 2,000 people
it's now the largest outbreak in Alberta
a woman in her 60s who worked there died
and more than 480 cases are connected to
the facility 360 workers are known to be
infected many other positive cases are
connected to carpooling and other living
arrangements between the employees the
Prime Minister confirmed today the two
planes one chartered by the federal
government the other by an unnamed
province flew to China to pick up
personal protection equipment for
frontline health care workers in Canada
but came back empty there are severe
restrictions on the ground in China in
terms of how long a plane can actually
stay in their airports before having to
leave whether it's full or not and at
the same time supply lines and truck
shipments to the airports are difficult
and interrupted by checkpoints and
quarantine measures for the most part
we've been able to navigate through
those and ensure that Canada has
received the equipment that it needs but
these two air plant airplanes were
forced to take
empty Canada's largest airline is
suspending all scheduled flights to and
from the United States starting on
Sunday
Air Canada says it made the decision
after the two countries agreed to extend
border restrictions for another 30 days
the company hopes to resume flights on
May 22nd but that depends on further
government restrictions
Air Canada has reduced scheduled flights
by more than 90 percent but it was still
running flights to 11 US destinations to
help repatriate Canadians those will all
stop on April 26 getting back to normal
in the u.s. coming up the state's set to
reopen in just days
in the u.s. some states are moving ahead
with plans to reopen some non-essential
stores and services despite the fact the
number of people who have tested
positive in the US for Kovac 19 has now
passed 800,000 we know not everyone who
has it has been tested either more than
45,000 people in the US have died
Jackson prosecco reports doors could be
open to the public in some places as
early as this week in small but vocal
groups protestors across the US are
demanding a return to regular life even
as the virus spreads as cases and
fatalities surged by the thousands each
day they're fighting stay at home orders
it's not a pandemic it's a panic Demick
message received in Georgia where the
governor announced plans to reopen
everything from barber shops to bowling
alleys by week Sanna we will get
Georgia's back to work safely without
undermining the progress that we all
have made progress means 500 new cases
of kovat 19 in the past day adding to
the 18 thousand cases and 800 deaths in
the state I talk with our public health
officials I don't see what that it's
based on anything that's logical
Georgia isn't alone South Carolina and
Tennessee are lifting restrictions too
we have to be able to accelerate as fast
as we can and as safely as we can not
one state meets White House guidelines
for reopening the economy the Trump
administration refuses to push back each
of the governor's can decide for
themselves whether they've reached
specific guidelines and specific areas
to safely and lockdowns
experts have said the US will need to
test as many people every day as it
currently does every week but the White
House seems preoccupied with a different
fight overnight president Donald Trump
tweeted plans to stop all immigration to
the u.s. ammu
meant to shore up his base of support at
a time when America's borders are
already effectively closed
Jackson Proust co Global News Washington
is Kim jong-un unwell ahead the mystery
in North Korea
you are watching global national there's
some confusion tonight about the health
of North Korean leader Kim Jong on some
unnamed US officials have suggested he
might be in grave danger because of
heart surgery but atop South Korean
official says Kim jong-un is conducting
normal activities these pictures are
from the last time he was seen in public
hours before that reported emergency
surgery that was on April 12th questions
about his health were raised after he
missed a birthday celebration for his
late grandfather North Korea's founder
one of the biggest events on that
country's calendar there's no doubt
about the health of one of the most
enduring world figures Queen Elizabeth
turned 90 for today and spent the day
quietly at Windsor Castle the palace
said the longest reigning monarch in
British history would not mark the day
in any special way she's in
self-isolation with her 98 year old
husband Prince Philip a palace did
release rare private footage of then
Princess Elizabeth as a child playing
with her younger sister Princess
Margaret
making masks and making a difference
next entrepreneurs give back during the
pandemic
this pandemic has changed our lives in
so many ways but it's also brought out
the best in lots of people people making
sacrifices to help others and giving
back a group of entrepreneurs in Toronto
is doing that they're helping the
country that welcomed their families
with open arms
Abigail Beeman has more on their made in
Canada solution to a problem facing the
whole world this is a clothing factory
that completely changed operations
inside a week there's a real need right
now for to relieve pressure on medical
green mass for people who need it the
most but also that you know with Kovan
19 there's been the economic hardships
are people losing their jobs
a small but quick-thinking team came up
with a plan to make non-medical masks I
asked a lot of questions about what what
would you do if you couldn't have first
best what second best the initiative is
called take care supply the masks
designed by Anna Maria Mount Forge
there's no designer without the sower
there's no restaurant owner without the
farmer we are all related they're made
by workers rehired after losing their
jobs in the köppen 19 crisis everyone
behind the project has a unique
perspective about giving back my mom is
from Vietnam and my dad Oh Ali is from
Iran all first-generation Canadians my
mother's side of the family is Polish
Holocaust survivors my dad is Chinese
orphaned at a young age and I think it's
really important for people to see how
the immigrant community in Canada is the
one that's holding us up right now I'm
really proud to be a part of this
because and and to be able to help
Canadians and that's because when my
parents were in need when they were
refugees from the Vietnam War Canada and
an incredible act of compassion decided
to welcome my parents and other boat
people when other countries are closing
their borders the initiative so popular
they've already sold 100,000 masks
therefore no
on health care workers but the need is
so pressing doctors and nurses have been
calling too I will personally go in and
actually prioritize their order the
message for everyone take care apical
Beeman
Global News Ottawa and that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm donor
Friesen in times of tragedy cartoonist
Michael Dadar is known for capturing the
mood of the nation today is no different
we leave you tonight with his tributes
to the victims of the shooting in Nova
Scotia his home province shoes
surrounding the boots of RCMP constable
Heidi Stephenson and last night's
beautiful sunset sky over Nova Scotia
brought a bit of Solace to people too
many Nova Scotians took to social media
to share the stunning view with the
hashtag Nova Scotia strong thanks for
watching take care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]